because the average gym owner takes down
36 000 a year in personal income I had
17 different people who work for me try
to start their version of my business
you were bankrupt on the brink of
divorce and you used all the stuff you
scaled to three locations and sold them
and now your family's financially set
off and like now you want to attack me
like I think now I can handle it a lot
better but at the time I just like I
felt so disenfranchised I just felt hurt
honestly because I really poured my soul
into trying to fix the gym industry when
I felt that way we created space and
then it just became an asset we owned
and that's why I was open to selling it